the Fiat ha Beckett all right back from
some more inside number nine this time
I'm talking about the understudy which I
was a little bit nervous going into now
I mentioned in the last one that I
thought we might be dealing with a bit
of a of a reverse Star Trek films things
where the odd number ones are good and
the even number ones are the bad ones
now I came into this this is an odd
number I was like oh okay but the thing
is a heck of a lot of commenters were
like ah the next couple meaning this one
in the one after aren't very good you
should just skip them a few people
flat-out said that so I I went into this
going oh boy because I because at the
very least I I seem to be in the vast
minority for my particular distaste for
last gasp I'm sorry not last gasp quiet
night in last gaps people don't seem to
like all that much but you know if I
disliked one of the ones that's so
beloved and everyone saying there's a
lousy one oh god what am I in for and I
liked it
I loved it and I think the thing is is
that to to make a comparison to some of
the things I said about the last gasp
this is very predictable there's the the
twist at the end is a little less
telegraphed than last gasp pause but
this pretty boy little boy ler play you
can you can see where this is going
pretty much from the get-go
but I still enjoyed and I think it has
to do with just because of the subject
matter or appeals to me I have tried my
hand at acting I've done theater not at
a professional level but you know I did
theater through high school through
college I did community theist LLL do
community theater every now and then
when I get the chance I'm still doing
performance obviously I do burlesque and
a whole bunch of other stuff so a well
done story about actors theatre has an
appeal for me now I do want to underline
well done because very often you know
characters and
up being caricatured and you know it's
frustrating with something you identify
with gets just done as a cliche and
while there is a certain amount of
cliche on display in terms of you know
the the bitter actor you know who wants
the stage all the time the the ambitious
understudies and stuff it's a little bit
cliche but it's also you know I I
connect with the roots of those cliches
like I've I've seen that and I've seen
you know the the inappropriate backstage
figure I've seen the the grumpy stage
manager I know I've I've seen these
things and so they even though they are
a bit cliche they bring a bit true to me
now does that mean anyone else should
like it no because if you don't connect
with the material inherently you're
probably gonna be underwhelmed by this
because like I said it is very
predictable especially if you know your
Shakespeare at all because they're doing
the Scottish play wait okay I gotta
force myself say they're doing Macbeth
so to show you how deep I am and uh and
that having you know tried to make a go
of it with acting generally actors don't
say the word Macbeth except in the play
itself they refer to it as the Scottish
play because is is it is considered to
be cursed and if you say the word
Macbeth under other circumstances
especially if you say it in a theatre
then you you bring down bad luck it's
it's right up there with saying good
luck as opposed to saying break a leg
because actors are stupidly
superstitious people theater people in
general really superstitious you would
not believe how many people are
convinced their theatres are haunted I
would say most of them believe that and
most of them aren't so but I you know I
connect with all that and it very much
draws its structure from Macbeth and
it's very blatant about that so again if
you know Macbeth you know where this is
going
in terms of the dethroning at the king
the guy who steps up pushed on by his
by his love interest and you know it's
all very familiar but I for the course
of a half-hour I was enjoying it like if
something like this got drawn out to
feature-length like ii-i've seen some
reinterpretations of Shakespeare both on
the stage and in film that sometimes
work but the ones that don't usually
it's because the gimmick for whatever
angle they are approaching it from
because almost nobody does Shakespeare
straight anymore it has to hold up
beyond the initial oh well that's kind
of clever and for the full length of a
play or a movie it usually doesn't if
they don't have if they haven't really
um you know gotten in it and really
worked the material well so for
something like this this is it this is a
trivial
oh it's Macbeth but it's backstage and
it like that's a pretty that's a pretty
basic gimmick but it's a gimmick that
works for the course of a half hour and
I do I mentioned the ending twist so
here's your plot spoiler warning if you
haven't watched already the reveal that
the person who has been secretly nudging
him along in the background was the
assistant to Tony the other act the
actor who the understudy replaced that
that wasn't bad because it was very
telegraphed that it was gonna be Laura
his his fiancee was the one you know
it's pretty obviously hinted that his
drink was spiked and he didn't know and
so it's it's hinted that it's Laura but
the reveal that it was someone else was
what's interesting and it I did figure
it out a little bit before she said it
but not very far before which is usually
the sign of a decent twist and that it
it's funny because it kind of plays into
a fear that actors have I don't know how
much people like that actually exist but
definitely actors worry about people
kind of latching on to them
like that and so it was for something
that's so embedded in theater having the
twist be you know this this fear made
manifest of the the obsessive fan that
that worked for me again I don't want to
oversell it it's probably the this will
come in at my third favorite of the five
that I've seen so far so it's not
amazing but considering how much people
were slagging it off
prior to my watching it know enjoyed it
so that's my thoughts online insight
number nine the understudy what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do whole bunch of buttons and links for
stuff to check out I've got a patreon so
look if you're interested so that'll
wrap it up folks remember your the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]